Welcome back everyone, you may have seen Henry Cavill just dropped a
Warhammer trailer
for his new Warhammer series
that he just announced that he's making like
literally as I'm making this video he just
announced it it answers a lot of questions
because it has been crazy the last several
weeks with everything that's happened with him
quitting The Witcher and now leaving the role
as Superman in the dceu or the DCU as they're
calling it now turns out the Warhammer series
is a big part of his decision to change a lot of
his plans not all of his plans but a big part of
his plans so I'll explain what's going on where
this all fits what it all means and if you have
no idea what Warhammer is I will explain that
too if you're brand new to the channel be sure
to subscribe to get all the videos of course
I'll do more trailer videos when he releases
them but like he just started making the series
so it's still meant to be very early days but
the big news if you weren't aware is that
Henry Cavill is now starring and producing
a live-action Warhammer series at Amazon like he's
one of the principles of actually making the show
he's not just an actor for hire like he was on The
Witcher it's been in the works for a while Amazon
is still locking down the rights like they've
actually been trying to make this get it going
for the last year and because he's producing it
means he's a much bigger part of the way that it
looks the way that it feels the entire series
not just in his character like I said on The
Witcher Netflix he was just an actor for hire
who the writers and producers would listen to
occasionally like he would have his own input
about the way they should do things and they
would say things like okay that's great we'll
take that into account when we're writing our
scripts for the next couple of episodes the next
season but they wouldn't be bound to do whatever
Henry Cavill wanted to do this time he's going
to be in control of the Warhammer series and if
you didn't realize that Henry Cavill is like the
most swole nerd you will ever find he has so much
nerd credit like the way that Vin Diesel and
Joe manginello are not so secret huge Dungeons
and Dragons nerds Henry Cavill is a huge Witcher
nerd but he's an even bigger Fanboy of Warhammer
like he says for the past 30 years he has
been a Warhammer Fanboy hardcore even when
they were promoting The Witcher season 2 you
may remember he and Joey Batey who play plays
jet ski or broke off on this huge side tangent
about their Warhammer tabletop gaming obsession
Henry let's start with you uh specifically which
universe or just I mean just say oh my goodness
ruling out The Witcher yeah um I mean
the easy answer is um Warhammer 40
000 that is my my jab um I have been into
it since I was 10. what's your army at the
moment uh custodies ah yeah I'm going I'm going
necrons okay all right cool yes were you into
this before or let's just assume that anything
nerdy I've been doing for a good thing oh wow we
could talk for hours yeah so yeah this is
that's that's my jam and that's the stuff
um I I do in my free time that's amazing
amazing um I'd love to see your your armies
your collect do you paint them yourself
I do yes that's so cool yeah is it
this is where you need to do in your trailers on
the off time during season three you paint many
painting time I love that they hijacked the
promotion of The Witcher season two to just
spend a whole bunch of time talking about their
Warhammer love in how they spend a bunch of time
on the set of The Witcher playing Warhammer
like while he was actually making The Witcher
season two he and joy Beatty were both playing
Warhammer games with each other I think there
was even a story that Henry Cavill almost missed
his audition for The Witcher before season one
because he was in the middle of crafting Warhammer
figures the same thing happened back when he was
cast to Superman for Man of Steel he missed Zack
Snyder's phone call telling him that he was going
to be his new Superman in the Man of Steel movie
you got the part because he was busy playing World
of Warcraft well the first time I got the call I
actually missed it I was playing World of Warcraft
at the time and I had my priorities straight
that's how big a fan of this kind of stuff he
is a while ago you probably saw him post a video
of the Warhammer people who actually make the game
giving him a huge tour back in February this year
just a little while ago now it turns out they were
probably doing that as part of the development of
this Warhammer series and these Warhammer movies
with Amazon he calls it a Warhammer Cinematic
Universe that they're developing so it sounds
like they'll start with the TV series and it will
eventually do Warhammer movies as well but the
idea is that when they posted this video they were
probably still in the middle of actually getting
the show going explaining part of the reason
why he probably jumped ship on The Witcher when
that was getting ready for season two there were a
couple reasons why he left the Witcher The Witcher
people have also said that they'll eventually
talk more about that when season three drops
in 2023 but they said that him leaving the show
started back when they were developing season two
so like him leaving The Witcher has been in the
works for a while now and when that was happening
he was still working on his deal with The Rock The
Black Adam to come back as Superman I just posted
a video yesterday about his announcement that he
was leaving Superman during that he all also said
that as recently as October of this year there
was a completely different plan in place for him
to come back and do Man of Steel too he'd already
filmed a Flash movie Cameo scene earlier this year
too who knows if they're going to take that out
of the movie now but by November of this year just
like a little while after Henry Cavill made his
big announcement that he was coming back like the
studio told him to tell everyone that he was back
as Superman right after that they finished hiring
James Gunn and then James Gunn and his partner
came up with their brand new 10-year plan for DC
movies that was completely different that's why
you're hearing about James Gunn canceling the
Snyder verse effectively like completely rebooting
the DC Universe getting rid of all the actors that
Zack Snyder had cast but literally a day after
Henry Cavill made his big Superman announcement
like he's leaving the role he releases this
Warhammer trailer so clearly he had the Warhammer
thing ready to go this past year like he'd been
working out in the background for a long time
and is probably the biggest reason why he left the
Witcher the Superman stuff probably also figured
into that a little bit but I think the series
is the bigger part of that but just to be clear
because he'd been quote unquote politely fired
as Superman and he'd quit The Witcher on his own
doesn't mean that he's going back to The Witcher
Henry Cavill now is probably going to be focusing
on the new Warhammer Series so it sounds like he's
going to be okay he'll come out of this okay and
probably making other movies that he previously
avoided because of his commitments to Superman
and The Witcher like answering Kevin feige's phone
calls playing a Marvel character doing the Mass
Effect movie that he teased a couple years ago
the sky is the limit for him he can do whatever
he wants to now this is his official statement
on the Warhammer trailer that he posted for 30
years I've dreamed of seeing a Warhammer Universe
in live action like I said he's been a fanboy of
Warhammer playing the game for the past 30 years
now after 22 years of experience as an actor
inside Hollywood I finally feel I have the skill
set and experience to guide a Warhammer Cinematic
Universe into life like I said Cinematic Universe
meaning movies and TV shows partnering with
Natalie viscuso at vertigo has been a blessing
beyond words probably because vertigo holds the
rights to the TV shows in the movies without her
we might not have found the perfect home at Amazon
meaning that the TV show will drop on Amazon
and it will give us the freedom to be true to
the massive scope of Warhammer just meaning that
Amazon's gonna let them do whatever they want to
do with the Warhammer series The Warhammer
movies to all you Warhammer fans out there
I promise to respect this IP we love I promise
to bring you something familiar and I Endeavor
to bring you something fantastic that is as of
yet unseen meaning that they haven't actually
made it yet like they're still trying to get it
going our first steps are to find our filmmaker
Creator writer watch this space my friends for the
emperor so if you're new to Warhammer I'll explain
what this means with some of his references here
but clearly he's been working on this for a long
time so I couldn't be happier for him it seems
like it's going to eventually be his main TV
show they haven't started filming yet like they
say they're looking for their actual filmmaker
like they're looking for a director they're
looking for writers meaning they probably
won't be able to release episodes until 2026
but it'd be like an eight episode series with
multiple seasons and the series would come before
they make a Warhammer movie and when he says for
the emperor in his quote there the emperor is one
of the major characters in the game the lore he's
like the Emperor of all mankind this god-level
being who achieves supreme power and I believe
that Henry Cavill's favorite Warhammer faction are
the custodies who are a genetically modified human
Warriors in the Bodyguards of the emperor so this
quote makes a little more sense in this context
I'm assuming this also means that he will not be
playing the actual emperor during the series he'll
be playing a member of this faction or like the
leader of this faction called the Captain General
Constantin Valder was the first leader of their
order so that might be who he's playing there's
a bunch of different types of Warhammer games
but primarily it's known as a tabletop game
it's way more popular outside the US because the
company that actually makes the game is a British
company called Games Workshop that was the company
giving him the big Warhammer tour in that video
that I posted earlier in the video it's a blend of
fantasy and science fiction like a lot of people
think of Warcraft and Starcraft mixed together if
it were more like a tabletop Dungeons and Dragons
type of game when you see Henry Cavill painting
his Warhammer figures here a big part of the
main version of the game is people just painting
building their physical army pieces like modeling
or crafting and for a lot of people actually
crafting the pieces is a much bigger part of the
fandom than actually playing or even winning the
game that's why when he and Joey Batey hijacked
that Witcher conversation to talk about their
Warhammer armies they were talking specifically
about who they spend all their time crafting
not about the actual mechanics or strategies
in winning the game just about actually creating
their pieces most Warhammer stories take place
in one of two shared universes the most popular
one is Warhammer 40 000 or Warhammer 40K that's
probably the universe that Henry Cavill is talking
about specifically it's a dystopian future sci-fi
setting with space elves space Orcs space nights
that's why people make the warcraft Starcraft
comparison because the universe is so vast there
are so many campaigns set all over the universe of
this setting there's a massive list of characters
obviously Henry Cavill series will probably only
focus on a small portion of them especially during
the first season like I said his post specifically
references the emperor in the custodian's
faction so I think it will feature those
characters specifically but like he says watch
this space he's talking about watch his Instagram
account watch his social media accounts and he'll
continue to make more announcements about what's
happening with the series later next year after it
starts to come together he'll probably reveal more
about what the actual story is the characters are
going to start out with in the actual part of the
timeline that they'll pick up in post all your
reactions in the comments below obviously I will
do more videos as we hear more about what he's
actually doing with the series everyone click here
to learn about that new Superman movie that DC is
making and what Henry Cavill said about leaving
Superman and click here to listen to Kit Harington
talk about the Game of Thrones Jon Snow Sequel
series thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!